Difficult and unexpected questions are always waiting for you at an interview!
First, take a deep breath and repeat the question.
Think back to your practicing sessions.
If the question is similar to one you have already practiced, then it is half as intimidating.
You can also break the question down into smaller parts, especially multi-part questions.
Example: "Tell me about a time of conflict with a customer...
...and the circumstances and how you resolved the issue."
By answering the first part, you set the scene of how things happened.
The second part is more important.
The interviewer will be less interested in the specifics,...
...but in how you managed to deal with the stressful situation.
This is true for most multi-part questions.
If you don't know how to answer a question, it's best to admit that you are not sure,...
...because most interviewers can tell when you make things up.
Say that you are going to look into this later so that you have this information in the future.
This shows sincerity and that you are prepared to learn.